ever swim with dolphins
have i
probably i don't know i've been in the
water i don't know what i mean on
purpose like you go oh no go to a
dolphin encounter no
i did it once and i like it didn't go
well
damn really what happened i brought my
mom
to the bahamas oh dude you don't bring
your mom to a dolphin encounter that was
great because she's a little saying she
she had uh
she we knew she had alzheimer's so i
just took her before she was getting bad
oh yeah tell her it's alaska huh
yeah
climate change ma i don't know yeah so
we go in the water and there's like this
11
minute video they show you a safety
video but it's [ __ ] dolphin so i just
took a nap
and then i'm in the and i'm like what
could go wrong it's a dolphin i'll tell
you so my mom they go uh genie genie you
get dotty and like this beautiful
dolphin comes out it's like a beaded
curtain it's like priceless right like
dottie
and my mom and this dolphin are like oh
my god you're so precious look like they
went to high school together like oh my
god
and they're like you get chipper like
the [ __ ] bullpen doors at yankee
stadium open and they play enter sandman
by metallica and there's a wall of water
coming at me and he's just like
coming at me i'm like i'm going to get
cut in half by a dolphin's head
oh my god he's just i was scared he's
like
coming right at me
hits the brakes wow rolls on his back
and he's floating on his back
across me with a look on his face like
you got it i'm all right man
so i'm like okay cool but he's got like
a little patch of white he's gray being
a patch of white like chest hair
i'm just kind of like oh you can touch
him i'm i'm rubbing his chest and what's
his body like soft or what is it it's
real soft i mean it's like like a kind
of a real hard spongy you know it's what
you i can't explain it but it's exactly
what you think it would feel like i
don't know what that is though i feel
like it would be hard hard hard like a
car it it well yeah but there's some
give to it it's like a hard foam at a
water park in the tubes
oh yeah yeah yeah so i'm petting his
chest and he's like scooching by
and what it said in the video that i
slept through was never ever under any
circumstances touch any of the dolphins
below their belly buttons
but he's going this way and i'm getting
his chest a little lower in his chest
look so i don't even realize that i'm
like jerking off a dolphin oh that's
like a massage parlor dude i'm like
right it's like a westwood boulevard
yeah like nothing came out but he just
goes and he like flips out and he starts
hitting me in the ribs with his head
in my life vest like dang dang i'm like
what's he doing i know what he's doing
is it powerful hitting or is it
lightning it's like i don't belong with
this aquatic mammal like i am a visitor
okay like bang bang and i know what he
was doing now i know what he was doing
he's trying to get me in the middle of
the lagoon where nobody could help me oh
wow then he goes underwater disappears
my mom and daddy are playing like
[ __ ] mahjong yeah and i'm like what's
with this guy where's chipper like treat
me like a tourist and then i feel like
him in my back
and i shouldn't know what a dolphin's
dick feels like
i shouldn't no you shouldn't never seen
one i've been down some rabbit holes on
pornhub yeah i've seen guys holding
their pregnant wives head getting
trained by brothers oh man i've seen
[ __ ] everything you could think of oh
man never seen a dolphin's deck never
seen a photo national geographic
slideshow
science oh i couldn't pick one out of a
dick lineup right now but let me tell
you something yeah when it's against
your body you know really it's the
aggression
like he was aggressive
and there's a space between my life vest
and my back oh yeah because it was too
big and that's where he got his dick oh
against my back between the life vest
how much dick is in a dolphin too much
yeah way too much like it's it's up my
back and his head's like here and i
don't know if it was just it was like
how long it i couldn't imagine even
being that long and i don't want to see
it nick really long don't put it up
there and i don't know how to yell like
hey really long dude does it feel like a
like a long finger does it feel like a
like a wiener does it feel like i felt
like he was like grabbing me from behind
but something was between us
like a mini it was it i ugh it's still
freaks you just i knew what it was why
were you wearing a big dude there's
nothing shadier than somebody wearing a
freaking big life jacket that's too big
well vacation they're either too small
you throw them to the side no no life
vest on vacation fits you
or they're xxls and they float up here
yeah meet up things like if not all the
life vests that's too big i'm you know
i'm looking to meet somebody you know
good to know hopefully yeah that's crazy
bro so i don't know how to yell like
hey hey your dolphins because the guys
are like up on these rocks like
your dolphin's dick is stuck between my
life vest and my back because i jerk
them off and he thinks it's my [ __ ]
so i just floated there and i started
yelling dolphin [ __ ]
dolphin i swear the guy turns to me and
he goes dolphins rock you know it buddy
i'm like no no that's not what i'm
saying dolphincock dolphincock
and then
so i'm completely alone and they give
you an 8x10 photo for free of your
encounter really so like my mom as bad
as her alzheimer's got
she'd be like who are you i'm like i'm
jj i'm your son who's the man in the
kitchen that's john that's your husband
she go did i ever show you the picture
of my friend dottie
and right next to it you can see me sort
of with all the whitewash but he's up
over my head my life vest over my head
like a hockey jersey in a fight god man
it sounds like that stanford rape case a
little bit it was rapey no it was it was
straight up a dolphin tried to [ __ ] me
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one